hello this is dennis allison
and i'm hosting ee 380 today
this is uh we're recording this on
october 26th
uh our speaker is andrew gelman
and he's uh he's a professor at cornell
and he is
a statistician and has been doing some
very
interesting work uh in the uh
area of uh the predictions people have
been making about the election
and that with that it's yours you've
gone
it's a privilege to be speaking to an ee
class
i went to mit many years ago and i was a
physics and
math major and at mit if you studied
physics you're considered to have your
head in the clouds so
a physicist at mit would be like
studying poetry
um or basket weaving somewhere else like
the
the students would all ask like my
friends would be like
why are you studying physics don't you
want to get a real job that kind of
thing
so as i said it's to be actually asked
to speak to an ee class i i feel like
i've
i've actually made it and i've succeeded
i've been involved in election
forecasting for a long time
not always using the polls though so
back in the early 90s
my colleague and i had a research
project
which was about why our
pre-election polls so variable when
elections are so predictable
and that was based on a phenomenon that
was
well known to political scientists but
not that well known to journalists which
was that
although the polls the election polls
would jump around
political scientists typically had a
good idea of who would win the election
based on information a year out like
based on the state of the economy
economic trends
incumbency results in previous elections
and and so forth
so in order to write a research paper
um we had to demonstrate that elections
could be predicted
so we did a simple election prediction
model um
predicting that bill clinton would would
beat george h.w
bush and it was not there's nothing
special about what we did we took a
bunch of existing models and kind of put
them together they
the only innovation of what we did was
we allowed for uncertainty at each in
each of the 50 states and before we came
along
there have been some nationwide
predictions which didn't
get the electoral college and then there
were some state-by-state predictions
but the state by state predictions
didn't account for the correlations
between the states
so we did that it was not a wonderful
prediction
for example we said that we expected
bill clinton to win texas
bill clinton didn't do that well in
texas we did not think that bill clinton
was going to win texas but our forecast
was based on information in our model
and one piece of information our model
is that bill clinton was a southerner
and southerners did better in southern
states it didn't really account for an
interaction and
it didn't account for increasing
political polarization
so where you're from is just less
important than it used to be it's much
more important which
party you are our model would have done
better had it used
pre-election polls like it polls from
texas would have told us that
george h.w bush was favored in texas
and other southern states not not just
texas which of course is also bush's
home state
but our we didn't use the polls on
purpose
because we were trying to demonstrate
that elections could be approximately
forecast
months ahead of time however in the year
since
journalists have been very interested in
poll aggregation and election
forecasting
this particular election 2020 i was
contacted a few months ago
i guess in maybe it was february by a
data journalist for the economist
magazine
they wanted to build an election
forecasting model combining
what i did before combining state and
national forecasts
but also combining pre-election polls
and it was a technical challenge so they
asked if if i could help out
and so i and political science student
helped them make their forecast
and the technical challenge is that
we have an election that's happening in
november and to predict the election
we have information like presidential
approval
state of the different measures of the
state of the economy
incumbency we have a regression type
model
trained on past elections also the
relative positions of the 50 states in
previous elections because usually
things are pretty stable
from one election to the next that is
aiming at election day but then we also
have polls
but a poll is a snapshot not a forecast
so we have a series of polls
um up to if it's day if it's currently
day x
we have polls all the way up to day x
and nothing between day x and the
election day
the way we connect the polls to election
day
is that we have a latent time series
model on the 50 dimensional vector which
is the positions of the 50
states the it was literally
joe biden's support among
people who support either biden or trump
in each of the 50 states on each day
between now and election day and all the
previous days too
the polls are a noisy signal that so
every poll has
sampling error that's the balls from the
urn sampling error that you learn in
your statistics or probability classes
also non-sampling error surveys um
have very high non-response rates you
know and we
empirically it turns out that the
the empirical error of election polls is
about twice
the stated margin of error and there are
different sources of nominee response
there are different sources of
non-sampling error there's
different polling houses some polling
houses favor the democrats some favor
the republicans
this is not by the way mostly attributed
i don't think this is
mostly attributed to um partisanship
like i don't think that it's like fox
news
is very partisan but fox news polling is
just a pollster
pollsters try to be accurate um paul
the reason why pollsters don't make
money off
most posters don't make money off of
opinion questions like who do you plan
to vote for for president
pollsters mostly make money off of
questions like what brand of
refrigerator are you trying to buy
what's your favorite internet browser
what would it take you to switch cable
tv companies
they also throw in some political
questions because then they can get in
the news they're advertising they're
like lost leaders
so if you're a pollster your motivation
i mean fox news has motivations but they
hire professional pollsters and if
you're a
professional pollster you want to get
the most accurate answer
because it's your rep on the line and
what you're selling
to the sellers of dishwasher soap
and consumer electronics
is not your partisanship you're selling
your polling acumen and your accuracy
so that's kind of we there's an economic
reason why we think polls will be not
too far off
that said why do why are pollsters not
all the same why do some posters have a
positive house effect and some of a
negative health effect
well those effects are small with rare
exceptions
the polls that favor biden are maybe one
percent favoring biden more than trump
and the pulse of favor
trump might be favoring trump one
percent more than the average poll
they're fairly small effects they occur
because different pollsters use
different methods
you might as well ask how come different
car companies have cars that have
different
gas mileage because they have different
factories they have different engineers
they're always trying to improve their
cars or their pulse their poles they're
always coming up with new ideas
so they're not all doing the exact same
thing so you need to account for that
um in addition there are these larger
non-response biases that we're concerned
about
like things like what happened in
minnesota michigan and wisconsin in 2016
when the state polls did not adjust for
i believe many of the state polls did
not adjust for education
surveys tend to have too many
well-educated voters
uh paul respond too many well-educated
people respond to polls and you have to
down weight them if you want to
get a more accurate answer so that
wasn't done well now they know to adjust
for that but there's always something
else so there's always potentially large
biases
there's also potentially national biases
in the polls
uh that maybe just systematically biden
supporters may be more or less likely to
be responding to the polls than trump
supporters
and then there are uncertainties at the
other end like voter turnout and
possible changes in
opinion so because of that for many
months we've forecast that biden would
get about 54
of the two-party vote it's been a very
stable forecast for two reasons
one the polls have not moved very much
three reasons
two even if the poles move a little bit
there's kind of a lot of other poles so
it takes like when you're averaging a
bunch of information
one more piece of information won't do
that much one pole is not going to shift
our forecast a lot
a series of polls would indicate that
there's a time series shift but you
would need that information
um and then the third piece of
information the third reason why it
hasn't jumped around that much is that
sometimes the reason why polls move
is what we call differential
non-response so after
the republican convention you might get
republicans fired up and more likely to
respond to polls
so the polls will show a republican
shift however you'll also see more
republicans
in this in the poll themselves and so
you can adjust for that
uh because it's we don't think that
there's this big shift in party
allegiance um
after the convention we think it's
non-response so we adjust for all these
things we end up saying we think biden's
going to get about 54
of the two-party vote but with
uncertainty maybe it could be
it's we're pretty sure it's going to be
between 51
and 57 um don't quote me on the exact
number we you can go to economist.com
and see what we have
but roughly um roughly that
if biden gets 51 of the vote he might
lose the election because of the
distribution of the votes and the
electoral college system okay that's all
background
so what i want to talk about my title is
how can we understand and evaluate
election forecasts
um now there is evaluating forecasts
probabilistic forecasts there's a big
literature on this
um going back at least to 1950 when
there was a paper
by uh in the monthly weather review i
believe it was
by breyer which is where the briar score
comes from which is something that's
used in probability forecasting
there's other things that are done a lot
of literature and calibration of
forecasts
if you say something is supposed to
occur 80 of the time
you can look at all the forecasts if
you've made 100 such forecasts it should
happen
80 times out of 100. forecasts can be
overconfident or underconfident
so example of an overconfident forecast
is i give you a bunch of
i give you a bunch of 95 intervals
and it turns out that they're only
correct 75
of the time so you are overconfident
that's very common
a lot of psychology studies have shown
that if you ask people to give
subjective 95 intervals
you have an uncertain quantity like what
the election is going to be
whatever ask people to give an upper and
a lower bound and say we want there to
be a 95
chance the truth lies within that bound
empirically people tend to give
intervals that only have about
two-thirds coverage
just it depends on the question but
that's just the way it is
people are overconfident you can also be
underconfident
what would be an example of
underconfidence suppose well one thing
would be my 95
intervals contain the true value 99
percent of the time that's sort of maybe
hard to see
let me give you a cleaner example
supposedly i now ask you to give me 50
intervals we can do that like our
forecast here's a 50
interval it's an hour right we think
there's a 50 chance the true value is
going to fall in this interval
what if i create 50 intervals because
that's my job and it turns out that
75 of them contain the true value well
the funny thing then i'm underconfident
i'm not providing the precision that i
could be providing to my customers i'm
not doing them a good service
on the other hand i might look pretty
good
because he said look i'm right 75 of the
time
if you get 50 intervals that are wrong
50 of the time then half the time you're
oh it fell out it's like your interval
then you have to explain oh no it's a 50
interval you know
whatever it's difficult so my point is
that they're in
their ins the communication involves
communication involves give and take it
involves incentives that involve goal it
involves goals
there's no kind of reason ahead of time
why people would think their intervals
would be calibrated
so that's why we talk about external
calibration
if somebody is in the business of
producing intervals we can take their
intervals and check their external
calibration
so for example the website 538.com does
sports forecasting
and they collected all the sports
forecasts they've ever made and they
found
that their 80 intervals contain the true
value 80
of the time like things like that very
highly calibrated worked very well and
sports betting like there's a lot of
people who do that so there are people
who bet on sports um who who who finance
sports bets and they're always
collecting these bets
and checking that the stated odds
are appropriate sometimes better
sometimes
there are bad odds out there and and the
bookies can get burned
but but typically they're they're pretty
good because there's a lot of economic
motivation to calibrate the sports
betting odds
um political betting is much different
there are thousands of sporting events
and each one is kind of independent of
all the others
they have a world series game then
there's another world series game each
has its own odds
there's not 50 there are not 50
presidential elections in the year
there's one presidential election
there's 50 little elections but if joe
biden
does better than expected in alabama
he'll probably do better than expected
in mississippi he'll probably do better
than expected in alaska
you'll probably do better than expected
everywhere not
everywhere for sure but if you
outperform
you can make graphs of this and
basically if you outperform then you'd
expect
you'd you'd expect to be out performing
in other places too
so i i cannot evaluate
my state level i can if i want to
evaluate my state level predictions
based on
calibration i can do that but those
evaluations will be correlated
so it's strictly if i want to think
statistically i'd need to evaluate them
using a multi-level model
or speaking casually it's not n equals
50 it's n equals 1 for each election
so what is n well in the title of my
talk i wrote n equals 15
that's an arbitrary number that's the
number of elections in the last 60 years
i'm not going to go back to 1787 and say
what predicted george washington's
stunning victory in the unopposed
election in 17
you know that when he was when he was
elected in 1788 right that doesn't make
any sense
i'm not even going to use it to predict
abraham lincoln's election
um or herbert hoover's election the
issues were
issues were different back then um there
the two parties had different roles
there
there are many periods in american
history where the parties were not even
close to balanced
there's a period of many decades near in
the 1800s and early 1900s when the
republicans were dominant
and where democrats didn't necessarily
mind if they didn't get the presidency
because they
had tammany hall in new york city they
could make more money that way than by
having a president it was a different
era
so maybe there are 15 elections but
maybe not even 15
because 60 years ago we did not have the
level of polarization that we have now
candidates like like i mean richard
nixon was considered a very
conservative right-wing republican big
anti-communist
uh you know big he hung out with joe
mccarthy
all that stuff nonetheless in the
context of today
nixon was would be considered bipartisan
he worked for the democratic
congress jimmy carter was was a
political moderate he was liberal on
some issues and conservative on others
reagan was very conservative he was kind
of ronald reagan was always ideological
as a politician that was one of his
selling points was his ideological
sincerity
but although he was extremely
ideological
the country was still there their voters
many of the voters were still split
between the parties and the parties
the political parties in congress were
more diverse and there were moderate
republicans and more cons and
conservative democrats in congress
things have changed so you could say we
don't have 15 past elections we only
have like six
past elections something like that that
are in the modern era
so we cannot evaluate the calibration of
forecasts
so that means okay like
this is engineering class right so it's
not civil engineering so i apologize but
you're building a bridge
right and you can't you you what's the
probability the bridge is going to fail
well you want it to be pretty low
right um well you can't you're not going
to find that out by building a million
bridge and finding out that only four of
them failed and so that you actually
have to have a model of the bridge
ultimately you have to see like does
your model make sense
so that's what we're doing here we so
that's that's what i want to talk about
how can we try to understand a forecast
and i can i can give i'll give you two
two examples and i'll i'm first going to
briefly talk about
some problems with our own forecast and
then i'll
and then i'll talk about um some issues
with the the forecast on on 5 38. so
um okay this is our the economist this
is our election forecast um
we give joe biden a 94 chance of winning
the
electoral college um
we estimate he'll get 350. i should say
someone asked me about this
um so we estimate he's going to get
between about 300 and 400 electoral
votes probably
i guess our our 95 interval is uh
two oh no this yeah our 95
interval for him is 237 to 421 and he
needs at least 270. so
we're saying losing is still within the
predictive interval for him he he could
lose or he could
crush we don't think he's going to get
500 electoral votes
um oh there's a funny i should say
there's some funny thing about the
electoral college because there's also
they they count the electoral votes of
maine and new hampshire
new maine and made in nebraska slightly
different than the other states so
our our estimated electoral vote
forecast might be off by one or two
because of that
um but not really a big deal but perhaps
i should
should mention it this is how the
forecast has changed over time
and if you look at the time series you
see that there was a point in
in april when they were considered even
there weren't really polls back in april
that's based on the fundamentals based
forecasts so
back in april the economy had yet to
crash
and and so back in april it looked like
it was kind of even money election
um then since then the economy has gone
downhill uh biden's chances have
improved slightly
in the past few weeks and it's sort of
hard to see that but if you if you
you could see a little bit of a trend
and that has to do with a combination of
improving polls for biden
and also that we're closer to the
election and so there's sort of less
time for there to be changes
um given how biden has such a big lead
in the polls you might wonder why we
don't think there's 100 chance
he'll win but as i said there could be
national there could be
polling errors at the national level
that could be causing that
we here i'm going to scroll down
i'm going to scroll down here we have
his chance of winning each state
um key states the popular vote okay
this is our estimate and 95 predictive
interval for his share of the
of the support of his support um among
the voters
so our estimate is that he was that
actually
he was more popular than trump we think
in in april but
that people uh biden's more popular than
before we're not counting any third
party votes here
um we find there's a night our
prediction
is that there's a 95 chance he'll get
more than half the vote
but again getting more than half the
vote won't necessarily win the
election for him i like this particular
graph
because not only does it have our
estimate it has the polls on it
and somebody it's really nice
when you put stuff online because people
find things so
someone looked at this graph now look
let's see
i'm going to blow up part of it here
okay
i'm going to blow up what's been
happening since october
um shoot sorry
okay so notice that since october
there's been almost all the the blue dot
this is biden support and this is
trump's where every dot's represented
twice it's
symmetric they add up to 100 by by
construction
so let's just look at biden support
every poll
all but two polls since october are
above the line
so somebody sent me an email and said
why is that this seems
weird some of the polls are above the 95
interval they're all above like what's
going wrong with your model
and well i i'll just say there's always
a possibility that we have a bug in our
code
and that we're like not using the polls
right so let me let me say that could be
but i talked to my collaborator and he
had he
made a couple points so the first point
is that
the dots are not as high but as much
higher than the line as you might think
because yes the highest dots are way up
here the lowest dots are down there if
the average of the dots they're around
here
it's hard to see in the scale but
they're about one percentage point
higher than the line
so it's not as much as you think there's
like a visual pattern
where you end up looking at the top of
the range rather than the middle
but then he said the other thing is that
um there
um the polls that don't correct for
party identification
um 10 uh were over we're showing biden
looking better than he is
because trump supporter supporters are
kind of discouraged and not responding
to the polls so much
and that's going to be explaining some
of that the other thing is that these
are national polls
and then they're also state polls and
apparently for some reason
biden's looking better in the national
polls than the state polls and and we
have separate graphs for each state with
that
now i'm sharing you all this not because
you're going to suddenly be an
expert on polling and indeed like i
might be getting some of these details
wrong
rather i'm trying to give you a sense of
how
we interrogate our models so remember as
i said
we cannot really we can't do much to
evaluate our models
externally so that requires this kind of
internal validation
well i will say there's something about
making forecasts you can lose but you
can't win
what i mean is we do this if biden gets
of the vote we lost i mean look look at
our interval
right if biden gets 50 of the vote then
we lost well of course we can say hey
unlikely things happen it fell outside
the 95 interval what can you do like you
bad luck i mean
we can say that and it might be true but
it's you know you don't
really want that to happen right should
only happen five percent of the time
so one problem with forecasting is even
if
everything you do is completely right
and your model is correct and your data
come from god
percent of the time your 95 interval
won't contain the value
so if i do a hundred high profile
forecasts i just do
one and i look bad well if i do 100 and
i do one that looks bad then i can say
the other 19 we're good you know if i do
and 20 and and five look bad i can say
the other 95 look good you know etc
but remember i don't have a hundred
elections
so i could do one and just get bad luck
you know
what can you say so but then the flip
side is
if it's right suppose biden gets 54.3 of
the vote
do i get to like pr you know preen 54.3
that's what we said or
forget 50 i mean you might not like to
look at the popular vote okay
suppose it's let's suppose it's the
electoral vote suppose
setting aside those two states where
they count them differently suppose
biden gets exactly 350 electoral votes
we say we predicted correctly no that's
ridiculous
our prediction is probabilistic we think
sure we maybe think 350 is the most
likely outcome we have a distribution so
we think the most likely outcomes
there's discreteness having to do with
the fact that there are large states
certain outcomes are more likely than
others the point is any of these things
would be consistent with our model
so first even if we're we think we're
wonderful we would not expect
our estimate to be correct second
if it happened to come out just where we
guessed we
should not get extra credit for getting
it just right
it doesn't work that way like for what
if we predict 49 out of 50 states
correct do we get to brag
no we don't brag we pick 49 out of 50
states correct because in expectation we
think we'll miss a few states
because if you go to the map of the
states
there are some toss-up states the ones
that are uncertain iowa
oh iowa ohio georgia basically we think
that we would only get approximately one
and a half of iowa and ohio and georgia
correct
uh texas um there aren't as many close
states as there sometimes are but the
point is we don't you wouldn't expect
that
so you can't win but you can lose
forecasting is kind of not not a great
game to be in
um if your reputation is what you care
about
um okay so here's an example of how we
lost
so someone here's a graph might someone
didn't they didn't send us this graph
but my collaborate oops sorry
my collaborator made this graph
i'm just trying to expand the make the
window so it's readable here
okay um it's we have
for we retrofitted our model sorry okay
we retrofitted our model to three past
elections 2008 2012 and 2016.
these are elections where a lot of poll
data and then
for each for each state we computed its
predictive interval based on
retrofitting
right to the the model um just using the
data in that year
and then we we isolated in red the
states where the 95
interval excluded the true value so
with 50 states you should expect to have
two and a half
that fall outside the 50 interval right
let's
point right that's .05 times 50 is two
and a half percent two and a half okay
but as you see we have more than two and
a half of the more than two and a half
states per election fell outside the
interval
now what's interesting is it's not it's
not always the same state sometimes it's
the same states and sometimes it isn't
um it's not always favoring one part or
the other
um in 2016 the
the mispredictions mostly favored
like we mostly our model mostly under
predicted trump
but not in california in 2012 it was all
over in 2008 it was it was kind of mixed
so the point is that like our 95
intervals are too short because
they're not contained the truth so
although but we can't be sure be but
remember i said that we only have a few
past elections and they're not
independent
they're not independent but given that
the errors are not all happening in the
same direction
it is kind of independent evidence that
there's a problem in our model
so i do think that our tales are too
short unusual things do happen in
politics
you do have really big polling errors
and we did not account for that
we you know our model so really we
should go back and use a longer
tail distribution of errors
and we didn't do that
for just because
when you add when you add one thing
again to take the analogy of building a
car or a bridge
when you add one thing to your machine
it can break other things
and so we did not right now this close
to the election we decided that this was
a fairly small error
we don't fully trust the tails of our
intervals i don't really think our
95 percent intervals i mean i think
we're probably we're overstating our
certainty
a little bit we're being overconfident
in our predictions
it didn't seem like a huge deal and we
weren't ready to start taking our model
apart and changing it
um two weeks before the election but
we're gonna look at in the future
um how do people discover this
because our code is open source it's not
a hundred percent open source part of
the stuff
i don't know the full detail of the
economist they didn't want people to
completely reproduce our 2020 forecast
for free
so the all the old data is completely
open source the new data
the code the new for 2020 most of the
code is open source but certain aspects
of the
of the fundamentals based model are are
closed actually
kind of complicated anyway we had enough
open source that the hive mind was able
to
find this problem for us okay now i want
to tell you a different story
and this is a story about
problems with the 538 election forecast
and i'm going to open in our window
so 538.com is a
um is a
as i said under an organization that
forecasts
elections and they also do sports
forecasting and
they do a lot of things they're like a i
guess kind of a sports and political
sports and politics news site um they
have done probabilistic election
forecasts in the past
they have a very good reputation because
in 2016
they gave donald trump something like a
two-thirds chance of well
they gave hillary clinton something like
a two-thirds chance of winning the
election
of course hillary clinton lost the
electoral college
but it was good for 538's reputation
because their probability of clinton
winning was lower than
everybody else's because really in 2016
all the evidence seemed to favor almost
all the evidence seemed to favor clinton
it would have been hard to make a
forecast according to reports
even the trump team did not think that
they were going to win the election
until the election actually happened um
but
538 has a very good reputation because
they were not
overconfident back in 2016.
then in 2020 they released a forecast a
couple months after we released ours
and people noticed
some funny things about their forecast
so one thing
was that the intervals the state
prediction intervals in their forecasts
were very wide
so for example when we were saying that
we thought
biden would get between something like
and 56 percent of the vote in florida
they were saying biden would get
somewhere between 42
and 60 and we just never really thought
our model never thought that biden was
going to get 60
in florida and we never thought that
that biden would only get 42 percent in
florida
their interval is much wider than ours
another example is that we have the
probability of
biden winning alabama as less than one
percent
and they have the probability of biden
winning alabama as being two percent
so they basically they have
unusual outcomes they assign higher
probability to
and in fact if you make them if you go
to their page
they say biden is very likely to win
california but they have a possibility
they think it's possible that trump will
win california
i don't think i would give trump winning
california much lower probability
they also think that biden might win
california by 60 points
which means he would get 80 percent of
the vote
and trump will get 20 percent i don't
think biden is going to get
79.4 percent of the vote in california
we
i just don't think these these extreme
points are possible
i mean they're they're mathematically
possible
um they're mathematically possible in
the same sense that the jets could win
the super bowl this year
but i don't think it's i don't think
it's going to happen um
so let's kind of pin that to the wall
here
um the idea being that they they are
consciously being
what they call conservative in their
forecast they're making their intervals
wider because they don't want to miss
some weird event like
like for example biden getting 80 of the
vote in california or trump winning
california
they want to allow for that in their
model and so now what
what does that do to you um so
i didn't know it was very difficult um
to understand this
but then one day somebody commented on
our blog
and they said hey five thirty because
their code is
oh it's not open so nobody knows what
they're actually doing they have a
description but they're not a
it's a trade secret so he said hey
someone commented and said hey
the simulations from the 538 model are
online you can download them so i
downloaded them
and i read them into r um and
i will do a screen share and we'll do
some r
rsr okay it's our open source statistics
platform
okay so i'm not going to go through each
line of code but i'll just say that
there was a file a json file
it was called sims sim.maps.json
and i read in the json file and i did
some pre-processing of the file
um and i'm gonna copy and cut copy and
paste the code
okay um and there was a weird thing they
had this
map they sometimes released maps showing
possible election outcomes
and made a map saying one possible
election outcome
was that biden wins 59 states and trump
wins one state
now i want you to think for a second if
trump were to win just one state
what would it be well they had new
jersey
okay well just you know anything can
happen right jets might win the super
bowl
right so let's i i'm
i created this condition i said well
wait
i should uh can i
you know what i should do you know what
i'm actually gonna do i'm actually gonna
well sorry okay um i have old code so
i'm not typing it in
um so i was i decided to condition on
um trump winning new jersey
and what i'm giving you now is trump's
probability of winning each state if he
wins new jersey
so it says that if trump wins new jersey
he has a 58 percent chance of winning
alaska
and 80 7 chance winning alabama and 89
chance of winning arkansas there's
something funny about an a 100
chance of winning new jersey right by
definition
um there's something funny about this
which is i think if trump won new jersey
he would win like
47 states like like
there's something that was not right
um and i saw i noticed alaska as the
first state
here it's so i thought i'd look at
alaska
so i'm going to print here first the
probability trump wins alaska if he wins
new jersey 58
what about the probability trump wins
alaska if biden wins new jersey
80 so this says that trump's
probability of winning alaska
is high is higher by well biden's almost
certainly going to win new jersey
so basically it says trump has an 80 80
chance of winning in alaska
but if he were to win new jersey he's
supposed to get 40
to vote in new jersey if he wins new
jersey it would be a 10 shift in his
favor
then his chance of winning alaska would
go down
i didn't understand that so i made a
graph
um wait i need sorry i'm not used to
this
manipulating while i'm on line here
okay okay
okay so here 538 produced 40 000
simulation draws these are the possible
outcomes of the election in new jersey
and alaska i shade it in if he wins new
jersey
there's essentially a zero correlation
between how well he does in new jersey
and how well he does in alaska
but there's a funny thing about the
model
which is that if he happens to win new
jersey
he's actually doing a little worse in
alaska that's kind of a weird thing
um now it's hard to read this graph
because of all the dots in the middle so
i just took a thousand random dots out
of the four thousand
now you can kind of see it better now
you're missing some extreme events but
they're very unlikely anyway
so so it's kind of trying to understand
how this is like
why so i think the reasoning is pretty
simple the reasoning is new jersey and
alaska are kind of completely different
states
so your uncertainty about new jersey
should be independent of your
uncertainty about alaska
but i don't think that's actually
correct because my understanding of
voting and politics is that
whoever is that when there's
that swings can happen at the national
level
if trump does much better than expected
in new jersey it's not that something
special happened in new jersey form or
even in the northeast
it's probably what we call a political
science of valence issue
like people people decided that he was
showing excellent leadership with the
coronavirus
or joe biden um was looking like a you
know looking very incompetent
or said something that people didn't
like like whatever it is it's not that
it's impossible to swing just one state
but in general we would expect to see
the states swinging together
so i decided to look at some other
states i looked at new jersey and
pennsylvania
and i'm going to end this in in in a
moment and just summarize things
here here are new jersey and so new
jersey and pennsylvania are positively
correlated
i don't think the the uncertainties in
them are possibly correlated so if he
wins in new jersey
then it's likely although there's still
this funny thing
if he wins new jersey it goes down here
and i'll get back to that
um i looked at alabama and mississippi
they have a super high correlation which
you know of course makes sense you would
expect that
they'd be correlated um wisconsin
pennsylvania
oh and then i looked for reasons i won't
get into i right now i looked at
washington and mississippi washington
being washington state not washington dc
um and we see a negative correlation
which i think is kind
of weird um we had some discussion on
the blog about why this is happening
and there's some error term in their
model in this 538 simulation
that acts kind of like a see-saw and
when one party one candidate does better
in certain
more democratic-leaning states they end
up doing worse in republican-leaning
states
and and so you get this behavior but i
don't really think this is quite right
um i think that if you told me that
trump won washington
i don't think that means that that would
be indication that he did really awesome
in mississippi because he managed to
appeal to liberals
i think what would happen is it would
really represent a national swing
so i think what occurred uh to get back
to this forecast
is that um forecasts get created by
putting together
lots of different features in the model
so i told you about our time series
model and our different error terms
the 538 they have their own method it's
not fully described
um the code isn't open but they're
basically also adding uncertainty terms
to they're adding uncertainty terms for
their forecast
um not through latent variables the way
we do though i think they're doing it by
kind of adding
errors they're independent errors of
different sorts
and i guess one they somehow don't seem
to have a very large national error term
but they do have these cancel these
negatively correlated state errors
um i think negatively correlated
error could be appropriate in certain
situations it's kind of a zero
if paul to the extent that it's like a
zero-sum game
you get more votes in one place and you
lose them somewhere else
um but i i as i said i don't really
think that
the polling errors and these changes in
public opinion quite work that way
i think there's some of that but i think
there's also a national swing
now i want to now get back to this
conservatism thing
if you have if you have 50 states so
this is some math
okay if i have a probability
distribution on 50 states and the 50
states are independent
and then i want to make a forecast for
the national average vote or the or the
electoral vote
the electoral college vote is a
non-linear transformation of of
of the state votes but it's still a form
of average
what's going to happen is you're
averaging 50 independent numbers and
you're going to get
a bit of cancellation you get a little
what we call the law of large numbers
and statistics and average is less
variable
than the individual components now it's
complicated because the electoral
college because it's a weighted average
it's you're not averaging 50 numbers if
you're just averaging 50 numbers you
divide the standard deviation by square
root of 50.
it's not quite that because some states
count more than others
but you get a kind of cancellation a lot
of large numbers affect
as a result to get a reasonably
uncertain national average prediction
you need to have very large
uncertainties in your individual states
now we in our fork we you can avoid that
and we avoided that in our forecast
by having very large cartilage positive
correlations between the states
so if your state uncertainties have
large
positive correlations then the average
of those 50 numbers or the weighted
average of those 50 numbers
is not much less variable than the
individual numbers themselves
because they're positively correlated
you don't get a kind of law of averages
thing happening
in our model if trump does better in new
jersey he's probably also doing better
in mississippi and everywhere else
um in this 538 model
they have some zero correlations and
some negative correlations
as a result for them to get the
uncertainty that they desire for the
national electoral college forecast
they need to have really wide
uncertainties in the state forecast
conversely if they were to make
reasonable uncertainties for the state
forecasts
with their low correlations they would
end up getting a national forecast
that's hyper precise that no one would
trust
so what i'm getting at is that our
exploration
of their the those simulations that they
gave
gave us insight into why
they had such wide uncertainties for the
individual states
um for florida and all the other states
so
we were able to kind of deduce so
so what i get i'm saying is that when
they had a super wide interval for
florida
i don't think it's because they said hey
we better allow for the possibility that
biden will only get 42
of the vote in florida because hey who
knows it might happen
the same with that ridiculous interval
for california it's not that
it's that they needed that in order to
to get the national uncertainty where
where they wanted it um so it's very
these forecasts have a lot of moving
parts
um and it might well be that the 538
national
forecast it could be fine indeed as i
said like i could i could see the case
that our intervals are too narrow like
um but i do think that that next time
they could do better
um by kind of working on their their
correlations and their uncertainties
that way they could get state level
forecasts that that made a little bit
more sense
but i i certainly i i don't want the
message to be that like they're so
horrible and we're so great the message
that i want to send
is that no forecast is perfect um
you want you don't you don't want to
forecast a single number
even if your only goal is to estimate
the electoral college vote you should
forecast all 50 states
if you have if you can do it forecast
the outcome in all 3000 counties of the
country
forecast things over time make your
forecasts as rich as they can possibly
be
give yourself ways to fail because you'd
rather fail
sooner than later the same with that
bridge if it's going to fail you want it
to fail in little places where it can be
fixed you don't want to wait until the
whole bridge cracks and falls
so i'm good luck in your engineering
careers
i hope you can apply these principles
thank you very much you know this is
just fascinating
and i can understand why you you get
caught up in it
because it's just so much going on
anyhow i know you have to go
thank you very much and i really
appreciate you taking the time to
to explain this all to us okay well i
hope the class goes well
and i thank you very much